hi welcome to Khan Academy I'm Kristen
deserva the chief learning officer and I
want to introduce you to conmigo kanmigo
is an empathetic tutor that can help
your students along their Learning
Journey it can prompt them to ask
questions it can answer and help them
through steps in problem solving and
lead them to their own aha moments
kanbigo is also your teacher guide and
we have a growing list of activities you
can use to support your class and your
teaching right now for creating lesson
hooks to introduce a topic to warm-ups
to writing rubrics you can even quickly
create a full lesson plan right from an
exercise article or video page and
targeted to your students interests
wonder what your students will see you
can check out what it's like to ask
answers to exercises as one of your
students would boiler conmigo doesn't
just give him the answer helps them get
there on their own we'll give you
summaries of your students conversation
so surface any safety issues something
we're very focused on kanigo learn more
and more how to support your class each
week and we're also still learning
please give us feedback on how conmigo
responds and what new things you'd love
to see that helps us improve and better
support new we can't wait for you to get
started thanks